I finally know what I have to do
You're unworthy
I cast you out
They just don't know when to give up.
I could do this all day.
This is nothing we were ever trained for
I'm bringing the party to you
I like her
Wow
I guess we're stuck together
Partners
Yeah
Are you ready
to become the hero
There is so much you don't know
Teach me
What happens now determines what happens to the rest of the world
It's my last day in LA so I thought I would just go live and see what you guys are doing so I have something
A little exciting to share with you today, I think I don't really know what it is
I got a parcel from none other than mr. Mark Ruffalo himself
And I thought I would open it
Online for you guys. I don't know what it is. I'm quite excited. See what it is
Whoa
Yo
That's dope
So I guess this is the New Avengers Avengers infinity war may 4th
Hi Tom I'm so excited to be working with you on infinity war
I thought you'd like to be the first to see the poster for the movie enjoy Mark Ruffalo
The crack team of spider-man and Hulk leaking you all the best information from behind the scenes here's the poster
They should just let them do all their press releases
Accidentally leaking stuff from now on but it's finally confirmed
It's time to start freaking out put the team on high alert
they're dropping the infinity war trailer tomorrow the funny thing about that is that you may have seen the Russos post the - like I
Reposted it so it's like okay
It's gonna come on Thursday
But then they drop this sort of like fan mash-up of Marvel phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 of like all the stuff
That's happened so far just to get people ready like oh
This is the culmination of everything that everybody's been freaking out about for so long and say we're dropping it tomorrow
So I wonder if the Russos were
Confused about when they were dropping it, or if there's people that manage the social media that we're just misscommunicating with people
But whatever totally doesn't matter
I'll be doing that IMAX take a giveaway all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
And leave a comment on the video
I'll announce a new winner at the end of this too - there'll be a bunch of Marvel stuff this week because it'll probably take a couple
Days to get through all the infinity war stuff, but the whole thing about this
I love the way they work the fans into the trailer tease like they really do like people
Reacting to their trailers some studio get really upset by that
They'll take videos down, but I think it's just a case-by-case basis like sometimes
They like it
and I think it just depends on what the fans are doing with the
material that belongs to the studios because technically all that footage like any of the images belong to them it's their IP
So it winds up being this funny gray area that I always try to tiptoe around
But they're just like full in on infinity war with the fans because the funny thing is is that if you've ever met people from
Marvel most of them don't know what's going on with infinity war either like a lot of them have nothing to do with the movie
Like you have the people that work in the comics sometimes
They get to see stuff early but most of the time they don't I
Did a breakdown of the leak footage earlier this week like I said, I think the actual trailer
They released whatever the first trailer is even if it's just a teaser trailer will be a shinier version of that
So there'll be some of the same footage that people saw at d23 in a comic-con but for the most part
They'll just be jumping around to all the big characters like who get shots of spider-man Iron Man in their new suits
You'll see what Thanos who looks like finally you'll see a version of him with the Infinity Gauntlet
But the whole thing of this movie is that it's supposed to be Thanos quest so he doesn't have all the gems by the end
of the movie
Everybody is still wondering about the soul gem
There's still a number of places that it could pop up and a lot of people are wondering about black panther because if they're featured
In the trailer in T'Challa and Winter Soldier and an army of Wakanda soldiers are getting ready to fight off some of the Black Order
It means they're coming for either vibranium or one of the infinity gems implying that there is an infinity gem in Wakanda
But the thing is is that we might actually not see that till the infinity war movie like we could go through the entire
Black Panther movie with him fighting the golden Jaguar for the throne of Wakanda without them ever
Referencing anything that's going to happen in infinity war I point you to the example of Thor in the way they marketed Thor Ragnarok
Think about what happens to that character at the end of the movie in the way all the trailers look you wouldn't have known about
That big twist just from seeing all the trailers so
Because the soul gem popping up somewhere is still kind of a secret it feels weird for them to spoil that with the infinity war
Trailer so I would be very surprised if we see that anywhere
Before next February when we get that black panther movie and like I said could just have the soul gem in
Infinity war and then the person who has the soul gem goes to Wakanda, and that's why the Black Order goes there
But I know you guys all have a thousand questions, so just post them in the comments below
And I'll try to address them when I do my infinity war trailer video
I'm gonna try and keep the video from being too long
We could talk about infinity war all day, so there's just some stuff that I'll just save for bonus videos
But there is one idea that I do want to tease because they've been talking about doing an a force movie during phase four sometime
so the other day they posted this picture they were doing the big photo shoot so all the female characters from Marvel got together
And took a picture, but even if it's going to be a while
They've actually started talking about doing an all-female team up movie
Which is basically the a force from the comics if you're not a big comic book reader, or you don't know what that is
It's just an all-female version of the Avengers led by she-hulk now obviously there are a couple of characters in
Comic book a force that they don't have in the movies yet like there's America Chavez, there's Spider Woman, there's She-Hulk
There's she hold so because it's gonna be a while before we see a movie like that
They could introduce some of the other supporting characters
And then just do that sometime during phase four but like Black Widow Tessa Thompson's Valkyrie. They've all said that they've had
Conversations with Kevin Feige about doing a female team up movie and a force is just the best opportunity to do that
But I know there are some of you that are also really hoping that at some point
They get crazy enough to try an ultimate movie
That would be like crazy cosmic Galactus level stuff, and it just depends on which characters
They're able to do because I don't think you could do ultimate without doing Galactus
And they can't do that without a sharing arrangement with Fox
So there's just a whole bunch of stuff happening this week obviously there's all the DC TV crisis stuff
That's happening my new video for that will post tonight
And I'll just post updates on infinity war and all that stuff as it drops the trailer will actually probably drop pretty early so just
Make sure you wake up really early or you just be prepared to get that alert when I post the video super early
But now's the time to get crazy make sure you keep an extra pair of pants on hand in case your body just completely shuts
Down the minute you see it
And if you weren't already excited enough we get infinity war in May next year the year after that we get Avengers 4 you
Don't have to wait two years to get that fourth Avengers film. It's almost
back-to-back, and then right after Avengers 4 we get spider-man homecoming 2
And that's the beginning of phase 4 like they're basically going to destroy the Marvel Universe and whenever we see
afterwards the New Avengers is gonna be nuts
Congratulations to the giveaway winner from my last video Alexander
Please private message me so I can get your contact details to answer your question
I'll call an audible and say Logan is my favorite Marvel movie even though technically. That's a Fox Marvel movie
But like I said
There'll be a new round of the giveaway when I post that trailer video tomorrow
Click here for my breakdown of the leaked trailer footage and click here for my Easter eggs from the first part of the crisis
Crossover, thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome. See you guys tonight